chris yeah carl ah see those 10 people
behind you
whoa when they get there they are
hunters go hide what the timer just
started we have five minutes
and if they kill you they get ten
thousand dollars let's go
later nerds bye me and the boys have to
do our best to blend in with society and
go as long as we can without being
killed let's get rid of this
yee haircut you're having a good day
cool let me steal your car
i'm pulling up to the clothing store the
hunters are about to be unleashed
five four i hope you have a good spot
three skip a few one
hunters go i'm shopping for clothes
let's go let's go boys
off with their heads move out give me
your car stop
use me ma'am we'll get a different car i
guess i have
almost eight million dollars i'm buying
a bunch of outfits i'm buying a bunch of
outfits the nightlife
the beat maker the skater excuse me sir
i need to commandeer your vehicle
sue me i don't care i'm being hunted
this is basically dreams manhunts that
he does in minecraft but in gta
yes i that doesn't look like me
oh styling i'm buying so many outfits i
have to do quick i have to go get a
haircut go go go
also i'm ditching that car it's probably
best if i walk around a bunch of npcs so
i don't just stand out i officially have
a new car are you also trying to blend
in with society
oh yeah i actually don't have a good
spot now i look nothing like what they
recognized me as
oh shoot should i change my clothes yeah
oh no
why did you guys tell me this what do
you mean we can't do all the work for
you i'm staking out every npc i see
yeah same oh my god i see their
characters just driving around
this is so scary one's getting kind of
close to me i'm just walking down the
street oh my god gaby ford just drove by
me someone's near me oh
someone just drove by in a pink van oh
that's that's surely someone they are
rapid oh yeah he's on the wrong side of
the road
oh my god i gotta steal a real car
because i want a car without a busted
window oh shoot no i just ran a red
light oh
so i gotta stop at this red light to
blend in dude these red lights take
forever in this game oh my god
i've been sitting here forever this is
so long
bro true story there's no chance that
they're gonna find me because they
wouldn't expect me with girls
i'm in the clear i think guys i'm going
to the airport yo follow me let's go to
the pier
hang on a sec that was us oh
oh i just found the car that carlos
stole there's somebody right beside me
and i'm
not currently in an actual turning lane
look at them on the map they're
everywhere oh my god he almost caught me
oh my god he almost hit me he just drove
right past me
he didn't notice that was a hunter i
haven't had anybody go past me dude and
i don't think i could take that
he just sat in his car and he just got
out i'm at the pier right now i don't
see anybody here
i can't blend in dang everything i do
feels so
sus like it doesn't feel like i could do
something correctly oh i just ran a red
light in front of one of them oh you're
dead you're dead you're dead oh
he just dropped past me oh my god so
many have driven past me yeah you don't
look suspicious at all
get out of the car and walk i'm in i'm
not hopping in should i buy a suit yeah
buy a suit be a businessman i have a
suit and a beanie now they'll never
suspect me
they'll be like that's just a normal
millennial at this rate i don't think
they'll ever find us
let's spice it up everyone has to be
shirtless now we are shirtless
all right now let's see how well we
blend in with no clothes
just follow this guy for a sec there's
no way that's an npc yeah he's running
he's running i think if you chase an
npc for too long it starts freaking out
and stuff carl we should go to the beach
so we blend in at shirtless yeah you'll
really blend in with your with your
jeans that you're wearing
[Music]
i stole a car right in front of people i
stole a car right in front of people
there's so many people around and i have
the cops
oh pink fans back pink fans in front of
oh my god that is a player
that's the hunter right there he cut me
off and didn't notice
i just drove past like five hunters oh
my god there's a hunter in front of me
and behind me right now
this video should just be titled traffic
simulator i can see the palm trees of
the beach
one of the hunters is right in front of
me i can tell because he just rammed a
car with a bus
there's literally three of them here oh
my gosh guys
i'm in the middle of the beehive we're
parking at the beach i'm heading
straight
to the fair bro i'm gonna get them i'm
gonna get carl somebody's coming to the
beach
oh i don't know what to do there's three
of them on my right wait they keep
ramming me they keep ramming me
oh my god they're above me right now i'm
at the pier as well and i'm on the pier
i'm on the pier this looks like a spot
where a guy with no shirt and jeans
would hang out
wait wait he's watching me he's watching
me oh shoot no no
i ran a red light to get away from him
two of them are right in front of me i
think this one guy's out to me oh
there's a guy right in front of me oh my
god
oh my god he hit me wait is that you
carl is that you jimmy jimmy run away
run away the guy's behind you
wait a minute i think i just found
someone hold on i'm not relenting
they're all here oh wait who's at the
front who's in front of me who's right
there
oh my god you're screwed oh they're onto
you carl they're on to you hey why me
what the heck it's literally you you did
this
oh my goodness i'm gonna find you i'm
driving to you jimmy i'm driving
straight to you
did he see me oh i think he saw me how
do i get out how do i get out of here
get him get a car get in the car go go
go
good luck oh carl go go go
oh my god which way do you go did he
take make a left i think he made it left
oh no oh no get out of the way i got
away from all of them
you're the one that did that jimmy you
brought literally all of them over to us
someone's gotta die where'd they go did
they leave i think they left
yeah i'm hiding in a fence right now i'm
spreading down the beach
oh look they're right there they're
right there if only they knew ten
thousand dollars was just sitting right
here i don't know where to go where he
could have gone anywhere
yo who is this let me in let me in get
in get in get in
ma'am 10 grand is on the line get out of
this car
what up chris shirtless bros and jeans
jet ski i'm on my way i'm on my way yo
we about to crash through the movie set
yeah but we're gonna have to go through
the movie set
it has to be them it's them oh yeah it's
gotta be now yeah yeah
oh oh it's not them it's not
no way i'm so confused i'm literally
spraying in the air
you have everybody at this beach is
running away from the ocean right now
what are you guys doing do you see my
bullets carl do you see it
you look so stupid where'd they go
that guy we saw at the pier though that
had to be one like yeah it had to be
that was him that was someone just three
shirtless dudes running down the beach
with an uzi
put away your gun i just want to say no
matter what happens
i'll always love you guys same good luck
suckers
i haven't seen anyone in so long wait
who's in this truck hey is the truck
sucks the impostor looking kind of sus
let's go i'm taking a boat to the
military base jimmy look at the chat
look at the chat
oh oh snap oh okay
they're snitching they have to be at the
beach then right yeah yeah i'm there
right now i'm looking for them
they just saw me i got reckless give me
your car give me your car give me your
car no they're going after me
he's in a in an orange like mustang near
the pier move
motorcycle oh my god i lost him they're
coming after me
who was that who is that i saw somebody
in a pink lambo chris
meet up with me let's go kill a hunter
oh my gosh
wait i can buy a widow maker for 500 000
this car's so slow i got everybody
coming after me
oh god oh no god why are they everywhere
is that someone wait wait that's him
that's him that's him that's chris oh my
god chase him chase i'm getting him
together i'm gonna die this is where i
die
go go go go come after you chris
got him
i can't use gta guns oh he's shooting me
i'm gonna die i'm one shot i'm watching
okay
oh oh chris no
oh jonah congratulations on killing
chris do you know what you just won uh
no clue
ten thousand dollars
go back in the 100 chat and try to kill
me and carl oh oh oh
is that him no that's a granny that's a
granny guys don't worry i'll shoot the
other hunters for you
i got killed by him it was him jimmy we
made it through a full night guys we
survived a whole day
oh wait oh except for chris i'm sad i
said this is such a good movie i'm
watching right now in the movie theater
oh i know where
there are i know where they're at i know
where the movie theater is at oh that's
them where are they at where are they at
right here oh we're right here someone's
coming up i'm about to just blow this
guy to smithereens
oh oh eat it hunter oh oh i got another
one you're a madman jimmy you've got
three hunters after you right now
oh he's gonna i can't move he's gonna be
down
[Applause]
why is he not dying say hello to my
little friend oh he's got a laser
my laser ran out of ammo aboard a
borough board ah give me this car
give me this oh don't wait that's a
hunter no no they're gonna kill me
they're gonna kill me jimmy i'm coming
i don't know if this is a hunter who's
this i don't know i just killed him get
out of here oh
jimmy got me jimmy hop in is this you
yes me get in
how do i switch weapons again oh no i
actually press the rope button get it
get it get it get it he's coming chris
get us away
our tires are flat we're at the
graveyard you know it's very fitting
that we're in a cemetery you know why
because one of us is about to die wait
one's under six one's under six
oh i killed one pink fans here i killed
the tango i killed the tango i killed
the tango
oh i got one i got one another one
approaching carl help help help
oh jimmy carl i need help jimmy jimmy
jimmy i'm on you i'm on you jimmy
these nerds suck kill this guy and take
his car ready ready come on
i killed him oh my god who's this carl
oh dude get off
get it get it get it no carl this might
be in buddy
i died oh i did it i live
porn hello congratulations on killing
carl
you just won ten thousand dollars no way
are you for real yep ten thousand
dollars no way man
thank you thank you never been so happy
for somebody to kill me congrats